have you ever been in an argument about
nuclear power we have and we found it
frustrating and confusing so let's try
and get to grips with this topic
[Music]
it all started in the 1940s after the
shock and horror of the war and the use
of the atomic bomb nuclear energy
promised to be a peaceful spin-off of
the new technology helping the world get
back on its feet everyone's imagination
was running wild would electricity
become free could nuclear power help
settle the antarctic would there be
nuclear-powered cars planes or houses it
seemed that this was just a few years of
hard work away
one thing was certain the future was
atomic
just a few years later there was a sort
of atomic age hangover as it turned out
nuclear power was very complicated and
very expensive turning physics into
engineering was easy on paper but hard
in real life also private companies
thought that nuclear power was much too
risky as an investment most of them
would much rather stick with gas coal
and oil but there were many people who
didn't just want to abandon the promise
of the atomic age an exciting new
technology the prospect of enormously
cheap electricity the prospect of being
independent of oil and gas imports and
in some cases a secret desire to possess
atomic weapons provided a strong
motivation to keep going
nuclear power's finest hour finally came
in the early 1970s when war in the
middle east caused oil prices to
skyrocket worldwide now commercial
interest and investment picked up at a
dazzling pace more than half of all the
nuclear reactors in the world were built
between 1970 and 1985 but which type of
reactor to build given how many
different types there were to choose
from
a surprising underdog candidate won the
day the light water reactor it wasn't
very innovative and it wasn't too
popular with scientists but it had some
decisive advantages it was there it
worked and it wasn't terribly expensive
so what does a light water reactor do
well the basic principle is shockingly
simple it heats up water using an
artificial chain reaction
nuclear fission releases several million
times more energy than any chemical
reaction could really heavy elements on
the brink of stability like uranium-235
get bombarded with neutrons the neutron
is absorbed but the result is unstable
most of the time it immediately splits
into fast-moving lighter elements some
additional free neutrons and energy in
the form of radiation the radiation
heats the surrounding water while the
neutrons repeat the process with other
atoms releasing more neutrons and
radiation in a closely controlled chain
reaction very different from the fast
destructive runaway reaction in an
atomic bomb
in our light water reactor a moderator
is needed to control the neutrons energy
simple ordinary water does the job which
is very practical since water is used to
drive the turbines anyway the light
water reactor became prevalent because
it's simple and cheap however it's
neither the safest most efficient nor
technically elegant nuclear reactor the
renewed nuclear hype lasted barely a
decade though in 1979 the three-mile
island nuclear plant in pennsylvania
barely escaped a catastrophe when its
core melted in 1986 the chernobyl
catastrophe directly threatened central
europe with a radioactive cloud and in
2011 the drawn out fukushima disaster
sparked new discussions and concerns
while in the 1980s 218 new nuclear power
reactors went live their number and
nuclear's global share of electricity
production has stagnated since the end
of the 80s so what's the situation today
today nuclear energy meets around 10 of
the world's energy demand there are
about 439 nuclear reactors in 31
countries about 70 new reactors are
under construction in 2015 most of them
in countries which are growing quickly
all in all 160 new reactors are planned
worldwide most nuclear reactors were
built more than 25 years ago with pretty
old technology more than eighty percent
are various types of light water reactor
today many countries are faced with a
choice the expensive replacement of the
aging reactors possibly with more
efficient but less tested models or a
move away from nuclear power towards
newer or older technology with different
cost and environmental impacts so should
we use nuclear energy the pro and contra
arguments will be presented here next
week subscribe and then you won't miss
it